bien un peu compliqué quand même très
compliqué mais c'est bien quand même bel
et bien plus compliqué compliqué ouais
hein
alors pour les gens de répliquer on a
une interview ici pour les gens
compliqué qui marche à tous les coups
c'est l'interview et saïda qu'est ce
qu'on peut vous souhaiter de pire en ce
moment
d'avoir une vie de conte de fées quels
défauts aimeriez-vous avoir être
menteuse quelle est la qualité que vous
regrettez d'avoir disponibles quels sont
les défauts que doit avoir un homme pour
vous séduire pervers qu'est-ce qui vous
donnerait envie d'être trompé par un
homme d'avoir du temps libre pendant
qu'il n'est pas là pour quelles raisons
seriez vous capable de refuser votre
plus belle histoire d'amour
si elle me rend heureuse qu'est-ce que
vous n'avez jamais dit à personne que je
suis très bien en tête à tête avec moi
en quoi aimeriez-vous être beaucoup plus
nulle en tir à la carabine qui ne
voudriez vous pas avoir comme femme oui
oui quelle insulte qui vous a fait le
plus plaisir
ils m'ont dit qu'elle est le compliment
qui vous énerve le plus le compliment de
dom qui a envie de me parler mais qui
j'ai pas envie de parler donc n'importe
quel compliment qui vient de quelqu'un à
qui j'ai pas envie de parler j'ai très
bien coiffé sa quel est le talent que
vous n'aimeriez pas avoir j'aimerais pas
savoir lire des extraits de mon livre
savoir faire des lectures de mon livre
j'ai bien fait de pas vous demander de
lire mais quel est le succès littéraire
que vous êtes content de ne pas avoir
écrit le petit prince quelle phrase ne
vous êtes vous jamais je vais ou chimie
quelle est la phrase que vous aimeriez
ne pas avoir écrite
alors oui c'est dans le premier livre
que j'ai écrit quand j'avais à peu près
12 ans et c'est mes larmes
n'ont de cesse de couler un peu l'eau
par qui aimeriez-vous être détesté par
le héros de mon prochain roman
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez que
quelqu'un vole mon téléphone portable
qu'elle est la mère mauvaises critiques
qu'on vous ait jamais faite
mon éditrice m'a dit un jour de creuser
la plaie elle trouvait que c'était pas
assez creusé donc ça m'a fait énormément
avancé
quel est le mot que vous ne connaissez
pas que vous préférez
rosa room castillon vous parler d'elle
c'est chez fayard
m